I just wanted to share it maybe this is
an ode do you allow oats this is I just
this is gonna sound fancy but I love
Trader Joe's so much I know it's just it
makes me so happy they're so nice
they're like it is it is an oasis of
sweetness in a in a desert of cruel
grocery stores where they just they're
so they're so indifferent but at Trader
Joe's they they're nice to each other
that's quite clear right away like they
all do each other's jobs and they and
they're nice to eat
it's communist clearly but it's not it's
not gray wool coat Soviet Communism I
would I would categorize the the
communism at Trader Joe's is Narnian but
during it obviously during the reign of
Aslan the lion not not during the White
Witch Aslan by the way the most obvious
Christ figure in the history of
literature
I I called it in fifth grade and a Jew
because we were reading lion which
wardrobe which is which is my
abbreviation of The Lion the Witch and
the warrior reading line which wardrobe
we got to the part we got to the part
where Aslan dies and and the kids were
distraught there was there was open
weeping and I said hold your tears
because if this goes where I think it's
going they'll be back on Sunday there
they're nice to each other that the
keshe always asks well first of all she
always complements me I'm one of the
items I chose and it sounds like she
does that with other people too but I I
don't care I don't care it's a gimmick I
don't care every time she says oh the
olive oil popcorn i I love this have you
tried it and I always make the same joke
I would say tried it I can barely keep
it in stock
[Applause]
which is it's so silly because I don't
have an inventory control issue I'm not
a I'm not a buyer so the point is is
that they make me so happy and then they
always say did you find everything you
were looking for today and but they mean
it like they say it everywhere but
they're just complying with the did you
find everything you were looking for Act
of 2009 they say it at the other grocery
stores but they're just the the subtext
is just say yes and go what do you want
me to do hold up the line while we try
to find your hundred calorie Oreos which
which by the way the hundred calorie
Oreos the secret they're not Oreos
luckily Oreo has built up a lot of
goodwill with me over the years
so I ever look it but they're there
chocolate flavored oyster crackers
that's all which is which is great if if
this is a big if if the soup of the day
is marshmallow bisque but it's not it's
not it's not it's clam chowder so they
say did you find everything you were
looking for today at Trader Joe's and
they mean it I've I've I've followed up
I said well last week I was here and I
got some Fairtrade conflict-free pumpkin
seeds but this week all you have is the
the conventional the young Fairtrade
blood computer are you out of the are
you out of the Fairtrade console affair
and then and then and then she rang a
bell and the stock boy who's also the
chief financial officer
and head of Human Resources he came
flying up the aisle with my pumpkin
seeds and and a bottle of spiced cider
that he felt was a fine compliment and
it was it it was the Pinot Noir to my
pumpkin seeds Chilean seabass
[Applause]
[Music]